[Musica]
questo gioco contiene luci che spara
bresciano e rumori e jump square e
[ __ ] storia sempre sempre questo è
non è che minchia che introduttivo a mi
muovo tale james luca the window
chiudere corten score dei figli dei
cortei in schiude li aveva ma deve fare
così questo qua a devo illuminare le
cose quando le illumina ok saronno hai
fatto benissimo ragazzi hanno fatto
veramente da dio è bellissimo ma i fan
dei il mio giorno di divertimento sono
non è non è quello non è questo il mio
giorni divertenti
io sto non mi sono divertito io non mi
sto divertendo in questo gioco di merda
e sono appena partito sono detti secondi
che gioco un attimo un attimo allora
quando si muove qualcosa lo devo
illuminare in poche parole prove 12 a
questo quadro quando è un po che succede
a ok quindi qualcosa di certo
che cos'è cos'è che succede quando cessa
[Musica]
io allora allora allora io non ho mai
giocato a un horror così difficile ma
non posso neanche iniziare nomi giro
porca [ __ ] o finito mi aveva messo
tutti o solo è saltato in pace peccato
avevo fatto il quadro cosa devo fare il
tagliando di merda start allora famme
capì con coprendo gli oggetti e
variabili però non so quali oggetti
posso prendere to spiegate c'è ecco così
mi crowd show non ho capito dove me ne
posso andare ma va bene speriamo che
succeda qualcosa così veloce riesco a un
santo di dio c'è qualcosa nel muro ma
cosa che devo fare
che cosa fa è quasi dice guarda la
finestra che è che chiudi leleco va bene
poi c'è altro loro tic tac complete del
puzzle eget out of the room before the
time is running out a ok ma non mi ha
spiegato come come battere gli altri
mercato solo come chiudere le serrande
saracinesche ma non mi ha spiegato
nient'altro c'è cosa devo fare
ah ah gli altri devo illuminare basta
questo devo fare
già così madonna non si capisce niente
però sentir romani giro a posto ora che
hai fatto dai ho fatto anno il primo
gioco che possa posto come si è fatto
questo è fatto
l'ho fatto ed è corte de cortesi cosa
fare le carte insegue nel letto nel
letto video mette le carte cioè le
lettere la spring locke come che ci ha
scritto non mi ricordo
ok sta arrivando il coso la mia età
battuta mentre la tuta metterò tutta 1 2
3 4 5 6 giu di breve sono fatto forse
sono fuggito
togli tirato da illuminano bravissimo ce
l'ho fatta sono fatta cioè nel senso
capitan sta tornando va bene amica che
palle infatti la vita si questo ha posto
però si sta svegliando oppure quello di
bianco madonna ragazzina che ansia
togliti la tutta la tuta o al di là la
brescia light madonna che quanto tempo
per farlo cosa cazzo devo fare questo lo
guardo
[Musica]
pensavo guardare per caso però è
riuscito all'inizio ne dica adesso ho
capito come entrare nell'ottica e non so
come fare evitare questo anche perché
non me l'hanno spiegato prove però tutto
il resto l'ho evitato quindi sono stato
anche bravo
non so come ma forse devo mettermi la
tuta pure con lui non lo so sai o
cercasse 3 si apre sia per i cassetti
aiuto che non è facile voce la chiave
ciapa la sento la kruger in chi la
finestra ho visto tizio fuori orribile
ok la finestra se ma lo vedo sala
ragazzi c'è freddi negli alberi orribile
cosa faccio o cristo è o uno l'altro è
che posso dare tutte e due
cioè che i freni nell'angolo attenzione
e tira fogna torcia quanto tempo che ha
posto cioè freddi nell'angolo volevo
fare li prende a chiave premi la prendi
a chiave potevo credere gli oggetti
predil a ok ragazzi sto gioco un inferno
problema non è tanto evitare la gente il
problema è che devi fare delle cose nel
mentre che non so cosa devi fare quindi
non puoi fare sto gioco era possibile
cos'è che devo fare le tue fare un
miliardo e mezzo di cose questo quello è
un macello fatta carino incredibile
allora freddi l'ho fatto è un mini
puzzle o java solo che il premier che
poi gli altri sono in fini bili cioè non
si capisce nulla può prendo la chiave
cosa me ne faccio non apre niente cifre
di fuori appena si avvicina tutte le
finestre stessa piscina che non è detto
eccola qua la chiave è in via premi la
april questo non si apre
va bene
chiudi madonna ce l'ho fatta ho evitato
la vita ha proposto devo tornare l'altra
chiave che non solo essi approccio un
altro cassetto lì ma non lo prendo
adesso perché c'è il tizio madonna
incredibile che mi salvo sempre
all'ultimo freddi e di nuovo alle
finestre ragazze tensione però devo
prima togliere questo ok adesso che
freddi alla finestra devo stare attento
perché devo andare a controllare qua
eccola qua niente questo affare non si
riesce la pelle chiavi mele infilo
nell'anno non si apre niente non è
possibile ma no non si sente orribile
non si sente è parente devo fare io qua
dovrei stare attento che non ci siano
madonna meno male che mi è venuto in
mente
meno male che mi è venuto meno male meno
male raga veramente rara europea era
persa questa m venuti meno di 7 cacchio
sta aprendo i lavori e perciò in giro un
attimo perché ho paura chi è o cosa è
successo non capisco
chi è o ai raffreddi nell'angolino era
freddo che ha posto a posto può solo
colpito madonna che han se la prendi
nell'angolino si sta disattivando mica
che bordello ok ok cesta parte ce l'ho
fatta mica due ore due ora sono stato
due ore cos'è 3780 50 3780 50 3780 50 ma
do 3780 50 37 8050 3780 50 37 8050
quello è quello cioè 3780 50 mi chiama
c'è scritto lì non va beh il martello
per scassare questo vice cassetti
attuali chiodi dai guarda tempo
cartoline di chiodi madonna è tolto
tutto oddio oddio che succede che chiede
aiuto lo sapete io e l'aveva scusa ma
dai avevo fatto tutto dai cosa le ho
fatto tutto ai ragazzi quindi io
veramente dato fondo al mio cervello che
uno problema immaginavate fosse uno solo
però vi sia piaciuto via è stato molto
complicato ma quanto fatto bene sul
gioco qui ragazzi spera vi sia piaciuto
cose e mi piace anche senso che si
chiede è sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo visto dai ragazzi
[Musica]